[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le débat ce soir
nous parlerons du revenu universel avec
cette question faut-il distribué à tous
les citoyens d'un même pays
un revenu à vie alors on trouve
l'origine de cette idée chez les
penseurs humanistes de la renaissance
est aujourd'hui le concept prend de plus
en plus de place dans le discours public
notamment comme solution pour éradiquer
la pauvreté
si le sujet passionne c'est sans doute
parce qu'il dépasse le clivage
gauche-droite des politiques de bords
très différent soutiennent en effet la
mesure des socialistes comme benoît
hamon au parti démocrate chrétien pour
des raisons différentes certes nous le
verrons et c'est une des mesures phare
de la prochaine présidentielle
alors est ce une bonne idée dans quelles
conditions serait-il intéressant de le
mettre en place
doit-il remplaçaient les aides
existantes
enfin quel coût pour les finances
publiques des questions auxquelles nous
tenterons de répondre ce soir avec nous
pour en débattre jean michel fourgous
mer les républicains d'elancourt et marc
de basquiat vous êtes économiste et
président de l'association pour
l'instauration d'un revenu d'existence
et vous avez également je crois
participé à la fondation du mouvement
français pour un revenu de base
bonsoir à tous les deux en soi l'idée
d'un revenu universel ne date pas d'hier
marque de basquiat on en trouve déjà
mention dans l' ouvrage l'utopie de
thomasz morts ensuite dans la justice
agraire de l'anglais thomas spain et
plus récemment l'économiste milton
friedman avait
on avait parlé l'idée donc qui refait
surface aujourd'hui a en fait déjà
effleuré de nombreux esprits c'est
effectivement très ancienne alors quand
on parle de thomas more c'est un petit
peu anciens et la manière d'étudier
formule était tellement loin de notre
préoccupation que je pense qu'on peut
passer un peu à côté mais néanmoins tome
aspects les plus intéressants
l'as eupen c'était un révolutionnaire un
anglais qu'il fallait réussir américaine
depuis l'éruption française volume tu
peux quelqu'un très éclectique et qui a
vu thi m'en expliquer que du fait de la
mise
ce montant était privé des terres
beaucoup de personnes n'avaient plus les
moyens d'accéder directement à la terre
qui permettrait de nourrir et donc pour
lui c'était la justification du fait
qu'il fallait donner une compensation à
chacun d'avoir de quoi se nourrir
au minimum il fait qu'on n'a plus accès
à la terre ça c'est vraiment la première
explication
thomas sky 1795 ensuite beaucoup de
choses ont été dites et si on veut
essayer de clarifier les choses bougent
et 4 3 gratuits de penser 3e minute
pensée sur 7
l'idée d'un revenu universel sont ni par
les égalitaristes ceux qui veulent
vraiment avoir une plus grande égalité
entre les personnes c'est une poche je
dirais de gauche très clairement ensuite
une approche plus sur la liberté
là vous avez des libéraux de droite ou
de gauche qui nous disent attendait si
des gens doivent être activés ce site s
ils doivent entreprendre
je vais prendre un boulot c'est la soupe
à leurs enfants il faut qu'ils aient au
minimum deux côtes nourrir non pas qu'on
se nourrir il ne peut pas être vraiment
vivre nous classe cette notion d'havard
la recherche d'une réelle liberté et 3e
de paris et rome ne pas penser c'est la
fatalité
les gens qui nous disent ça divise a
pour but française la fraternité qui dit
ben les personnes qui sont dans le
dénuement les pauvres les personnes en
difficulté il faut voir un regard voilà
par rapport à elle et donc il faut une
sollicitude particulière et donc ça
c'est plutôt ce qu'on voit chez les
chrétiens catholiques
je suis de formation également trouvé
vraiment une diversité de regards sur
sur cette question du rôle universel qui
rend les choses un peu compliquées qui
comparaît avec une personne qu'elle soit
de gauche ou de droite ou 17 ans peuvent
ouvrir sa manière à elle grâce à vous
énerver
alors que finalement le cnes plus
concrète technique d'être est la même
pour les deux assesseurs on verra les
les différences plus tard jean michel
fourgous vous voyez le fil de l'histoire
finalement est-ce que vous vous
retrouveriez pas dans un de ces groupes
de pensée mais écoutez moi aussi je
regarde je n'ai montreuil c'est chez les
communistes île communiste
ces sites a vu le communisme c'est très
beau il vous présente un modèle parfait
de société alors quand ils arrivent au
pouvoir mais surtout mieux que c'est pas
facile il commence d'abord à enfermer et
torturé et tué tous les gens qui ne le
dira pas au modèle parfait et quand ils
ont comme tous ont mis non personne
seule planète bon après il passe la
deuxième phase qui est donc de
construire ce fameux modèle parfait et
là en général c'est une catastrophe
le pays est ruiné les élites sont soit
en prison soit à la morgue reçoit partie
du pays
donc voyez c c'est une forme de on veut
aller contre le communisme lutte contre
le fait qu' il y en a un qui a plus
d'idées qui veut travailler plus quelle
que soit son origine d'ailleurs et on
veut lui donner un peu
la même chose que celui qui qui m'ont a
pas ce goût au travail qui n est pas
innovant qui n'a pas bon qui ne n'est
pas responsable
donc donc attention dans ce pays on est
toujours dans un débat de ce type là ça
c'est du débat répartition nist les
français aujourd'hui attendent un débat
sur comment produit la richesse et on
continue et on continue et on continue
on revient à nouveau dans le socialisme
qui dit on va parler de redistribution
de modifier de répartition jamais pas un
mot sur comment va voir de nouvelles
recettes on a besoin de nouvelles
recettes pour redistribuer à mais
d'abord parce que l'autre alors deux
candidats que vous soutenez à la
présidentielle propose lui une sorte de
rossillon de recel c'est autre chose
c'est parvenu c'est simplement il y a
des tas d'allocation des minima sociaux
des aides aux logements des aides et
donc c'est de conques athénée comme on
dit tout cela de les rassembler et d'en
faire une allocation sociale unique
ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait de
donner un revenu déconnecté de
l'entreprise vous imaginez mais les
marxistes d'ailleurs monsieur benoît
hamon fourche à foncer là dedans on va
pouvoir couper le lien entre travail et
l'entreprise
le parti démocrate droite
vous savez il y avait des gens de chez
nous qui avait soutenu les 35 heures
c'est une catastrophe
ça coûte 25 milliards par an depuis 2000
on en est à 4 5 milliards de dettes
supplémentaires et on a plus de 6
millions de chômeurs et ça devrait
résoudre le problème du chômage donc
céder les modèles théoriques
on connaît mois et au seuil a rien de
pire que jeu dont je me méfie que que de
ces grands modèles théoriques qui se
comme le communisme la société parfaite
alors marc demarcq de basquiat part de
leur revenu universel une idées
marxistes pas vraiment alors si ça peut
persister dans les comms ds3 celui de
penser que les risques sont en général
marxiste justement les libéraux devaient
le marché tout pas qu'il se fait des
libéraux de droit du bureau de gauche se
montrent tout et vous avez ensuite la
fatalité est là c'est pas une question
d'être sans divertissement donc et soul
et c'est ça qui rend les choses très
compliquées parce que et c'est un sujet
qui est très facile à caricaturer
elle a fait une très belle caricature
c'est facile de caricaturer
coface communiste c'est extrêmement
simple effectivement on va donner mettre
en commun des ressources pour que tout
le monde ait de quoi être debout c'est
beau c'est beau look sexy
donc c'est forcément communistes nous
c'est forcément staline donc forcément
de goulag ça pas une caricature c'est un
peu ridicule mais je pense qu'il faut
arriver à dépasser ce débat qui suit on
reste là dedans effectivement je suis un
peu triste un peu pauvre voyez bien dans
quel le débat c'est pas ça le débat
c'est de dire que pour que les personnes
sont en état de fonctionner une personne
physique un être vivant à swat a
continué il faut qu'elles soient nourris
il faut qu'elle soit habillée tout câlin
toit pour vivre tout le monde est
d'accord là dessus a évoqué le poisson
se soigne et d'optimisation de fosseux
question à quel point cette étude du cas
également
ça c'est le sont les fonctions de base
d'un état digne de ce nom
et l'idée c'est de fournir les moyens à
tous il est bien mieux dominer rare si
on réunit réseau et offrir de manière
efficace
ça fait des décennies qu'on bricole on
ajoute du rsa vers ci de là je parle là
du 6 du ca en permanence ce n'est pas
efficace
alors je réponds c'est des choses
justement une première idée chez les
défenseurs de ce revenu universel et
notamment à droite
ces deux ça permettrait de rationaliser
les aides sociales
aujourd'hui il ya à peu près une dizaine
de minima sociaux vous l'avez dit le rsa
l'allocation de solidarité spécifique
etc
donc ça c'est quand même une première
idée forte qu'on retrouve à gauche et la
droite
oui c'est c'est là la question de
simplifier les aides sociales et de
fixer un plafond qui montre bien que
attendre les allocations n'est pas plus
rentable que de travailler donc bien sûr
qu'il faut fixer une règle c'est ce que
propose fillon maintenant c'est pour ça
que notre ami
on pose des chaussures laquelle on peut
réfléchir mais à ne pas céder à cette à
ce revenu de dire vous pouvez avoir un
revenu minimum je crois consciemment le
porte entre 750 euros et mille euros
c'est à dire vous n'avez plus besoin de
travailler le rêve de l'extrême gauche
c'est de couper le lien entre le travail
et l'entreprise entre le salaire et
travaille dans l'entreprise ça c'est
mortel et on revient à la logique
communiste j'ai dis pas qu'on vous ait
l'envié des gens goulag
je dis simplement que culturellement on
retrouve la même dialectique c'est que
le monde du travail est négatif c'est
une valeur négative
il faut donner un salaire sans passer
par le travail sans passer par la case
travaille alors pour un handicapé c'est
normal pour quelqu'un qui ait touché
momentanément par un malheur c'est
normal voyez mes mais de présenter ça
pour tous les français et en plus on
sera le seul pays au monde parce que je
regarde qu'eux en alaska savez ttc en 82
on va en parler parce que je veux voir
c'est pour voir ce qui s'est fait déjà
mal de basquiat avec 700 euros on peut
pas véritablement vivre donc c'est quand
même pensé par certains comme un revenu
complémentaire plutôt qu'à un revenu
d'existence alors sur le montant il faut
être extrêmement précis et donc merci de
citer deux clés la proposition qui est
révoqué d'un revenu à 800000 euros
typiquement une aberration pourquoi dans
votre tête vous aviez proposé 382 euros
si je n'avais l'histoire ça 2010-2011
bravo 300 pages la norme et son rôle
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui proposé 800 ou 1000 euros
c'est quelque chose qui effectivement
destructeur des soutras duc de l'aigle
lui parce qu'effectivement là on va en
plafonner le niveau de revenus de
quelqu'un qui travaille donc là on a
introduit une désincitation travail qui
est massive
donc évidemment je suis totalement
d'accord avec monsieur fau booth c'est
inacceptable c'est une idée loufoque
loufoque à tel point que le sénat qui
fait un travail assez importants sur le
sujet avec ce bon rapport sur lors d'une
base de l'utopie à l'exportation mécénat
injustement écarté toutes ces idées
loufoques
il envoie la saisie de données des
montants qui permettrait de patrouille
et ça n'a aucun sens c'est stupide et le
sénat
ce travail était fait par des sénateurs
de droite de gauche les écologistes même
du communiste même des communistes c'est
déjà pas écarté un peu toutes ces idées
qui circulent effectivement que des
fantaisistes un de lui sans renoncer
totalement fantaisistes mais bon il faut
bien se repérer par rapport à
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est quoi je vous avais qui
n'a pas de ressources qui vont dans le
dénuement
il va demander le rsa le rsa c'est ça
135 euros
c'est qu'à 130 12 euros car il faut
toujours quasiment toujours qu'on ne
peut plus payer vous êtes au courant
dans les conseils départementaux
il a eu ses 412 euros
c'est ce que touche vraiment la personne
à côté de ça il est né de logements sa
9e logement donc le montant réel du las
à ses 410 euros projet pour 2016 le
montant que propre que le propose ira en
continuité du système actuel ces 481
veut ça peut être plus universel écoutez
ça va bien entendu à cause de ça il faut
aider les gens à songer à 80 euros l
encours à versailles ou à paris on
change pas on a du mal à se loger et se
nourrir en même temps à ce prix là donc
il faut qu'ils auraient les moyens de se
loger et en quelqu'un et logés dont 480
euros c'est à dire 16 euros par jour
pour se nourrir s'habiller payer son
forfait téléphonique genre de choses bon
c'est pas une vie fantastique mais on
survit on survit et moi je dis que dans
un pays comme le nôtre qui a le niveau
de richesse que nous connaissons nous
pouvons tout à fait assuré cela est
assuré cela tout le monde
ce n'est pas d'hier allez vous vous
méritez vous êtes si vous êtes à andré
blanc c'est tout le monde dans l'avoir
et donc tout le monde les c'est une
réforme fiscale et chauffage
jean michel fourgous mais alors quel
salon asian qui vous allez dire à votre
banque et demi les minima sociaux ça
existe tout le monde est pourtant encore
faut fixer des règles bien sûr un mais
mais qu'est ce que vous allez dire veut
de banque et là vous avez ça coûte 300
milliards ont quand même notre
proposition
les estimations de la rosière de
compensation retranchera 500 milliards
après pour le final ce nom même un think
tank socialiste un bon trois cent mille
à trois mille yahoo c'est ce que 300
milliards est ce que les français savent
ce que c'est ça les ensembles les
retraites c'est d'une part l'ensemble
des retraites mais c'est aussi
l'ensemble des recettes fiscales de
l'état français c'est à dire l'ensemble
des impôts sur le revenu à 8 ans alors
si environ 380 mais après quand vous
rembourser ce que doit rembourser l'état
il vous reste plus que moins 300
milliards donc en est les recettes c'est
environ entre 280 et 300 millions par
l'état ou par les pales de kuyt you call
me parlez pas des hôpitaux prévoit tout
ça à cause de tant d'années
or en fiscal non donc là si demain il
fallait lancer une nouvelle allocation
un nouveau revenu pour les français il
faut être ou et 3,5 milliards
donc ça veut dire que ça correspond à
doubler les impôts doubler la tva
doublez votre approche aujourd'hui pas
de pot soit doubler l'impôt sur les
sociétés vous allez avoir des départs
d'entreprise et puis même doubler la
taxe sur l'essence qui pèse près 70% sur
le plein de super bons donc est ce que
vous vous rendez compte
et on est toujours dans le débat
répartition n'est à aucun moment notre
ami ingénieur nos amis socialistes
communistes aucun vient sur le débat le
vrai sol débat c'est comment on augmente
la richesse de ce pays
et souvenez-vous les ans vous me
rappelez vous savez vous me rappelez la
la la la tendance marcuse de la
croissance zéro vous souvenez pas de
cette fumisterie de première il y avait
un type que tu es plus un philosophe
marc qui proposait il ya du puca n'ont
pas de croissance
tout allait s'arranger là vous avez 2300
milliards de dette c'est à dire que vous
devez faire une croissance forte
pas une croissance de 0,5 comme vous
vous traînez on se traîne depuis quatre
ans contre un drop aux engagements
l'un d'eux s'était c'était tout pour
cent 0,5 en moyenne depuis quatre ans il
vous faut 3 4% pour payer vos dettes
pour payer les retraites les 300 dinars
dont vous avez parlé et mais est ce que
est ce que la répartition globale est ce
que vous vous rendez compte que demain
on va on va mettre les gens à déjà avec
les 35 ans seul pays au monde qui a pris
les 35 heures on va rajouter maintenant
de donner un revenu pour ne pas
travailler parce que quelque part et
c'est ce que dit monsieur hamon alors
peut-être que vous êtes un peu je vous
sais pas mais finalement je suis gentil
bien sûr de chalon s'est lui hissé il va
il va fonder en les 38 32 heures maire
d'hellemmes et puis le revenu minimum
universel sur goom travailler dans
l'entreprise vous avez un remarques des
matières la réponse sur le financement
alors il y a des idées
d'ailleurs chez benoît hamon et c'est
sur quoi tu ne sont pas celles qui ont
ils bien d'évoquer mesure voilà donc sur
le financement déjà ce que vous avez dit
il faut déjà que nous a pas corrigé le
vélib
il n'y avions pas question de rajouter
300 milliards d'impôts complémentaires
ça n'a aucun sens cette histoire là
c'est nous et en panne sans fiction et à
mesure que 2 300 milliards les trouver
où les 300 milliards tu es tout la
personne qui me recevoir figurez vous
alors je vous explique aujourd'hui
l'impôt son revenu actuel que nous
payons tout ça ce sont 78 milliards de
collecte seront douze meilleurs c'est le
premier outil de redistribution en
france c'est à dire que dans la
population française
une petite moitié et va payer de la peau
plus ou moins pour beaucoup trop peu et
une bonne partie de la population ne
paye pas du tout l'impression de revenus
comme étant en place un revenu universel
de 480 euros par mois pour tout le monde
on meurt également en place un nouvel
impôt qui va remplacer ce fameux
importants revenus qui pose pas de
problème et qui sera progressif qui lui
va prendre dès le premier euro
une contribution de chacun chacun dès
qu'il a un revenu pas à cotiser dans
certains pour l'heure la collecte à
vouloir le pauvre va payer
il veut payer 30 % d'impôt absolument ne
pas trop y croire
23 pensait sans doute pas d'impôts qui
va payer l'entretien de produits 23% -
les 480 en question c'est ça que
quelqu'un
qui a un revenu qui aurait un revenu de
0-2 recevoir 480 il sert à rien qui
paiera 23% 2 0 par contre quelqu'un qui
a un revenu de mille euros pays 23%
c'est lui le cope 230 euros - les 480
vous faire il va recevoir 250
c'est extrêmement simple et ceci est
équilibrée par nature xt l'écran ça
c'est extrêmement simple c'est que tout
le monde acquis de 23% sur ce revenu et
chacun va recevoir cette forme de crédit
d'impôt ou de revenus versés ou pas ça
comme on veut
qui fait que soit on a des hauts revenus
en allant voir quand même payer plus que
l'on reçoit son aide aux vues plus bas
on va recevoir plus que ce que l'on paye
et ceux ci étaient qui durait et en sol
on n'est pas sûrs et transmis leur on
est sur 96 milliard d'âmes dernières
estimations ça c'est donc une mesure de
financement
c'est la mesure qui ai l'habitude
laquelle la plus robuste prenez impôt
sur le revenu qui était déjà affecté
autre chose est au courant mais l'impôt
sur le revenu il ya chuté à quoi ils
affectés à des tas de haut à financer
les ressorts des tas de choses le nom le
budget de l'éducation nationale 65
milliards comme lors des veillées qui
bougeait si vous enlevez la défense la
dette 50 mélange amandinois m'en propose
la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
donc ça c'est je crois 80 milliards par
an
les niches fiscales 90 milliards par an
les fraudes
aux cotisations sociales je crois 69
donc il va puiser de l'argent là aussi
ailleurs un cadeau de profession lutte
contre les fuites fiscales manque ni
quand ni comment on fait pour lutter
contre vous diriez que cessna clair
encore sur la mise en application dans
le cadre d'un discours des politiques
qui passent leurs marques après dans nos
sessions passionnant puissance 1000
depuis 27 ans était temps de trajet
coûte rien tu nous c'est extrêmement
clair et quand je leur prends tu
essayais de viol est les rues qu'elle
ait cédé récemment sa manière mais c'est
les rues c'est très clair pour lui aussi
non pas dans une forme de crédit d'impôt
qui s'esquissait s'accompagne d'une
claque taxes c'est ce que nous mettrons
pas ce que viennent vous l'écrire et
savons que ça fonctionne et la souleille
qu'on soit de droite ou de gauche et les
sénateurs entreprises mais aussi celle
accordée à la fin de vie cela il est
mort ce qui fonctionne c'est un bien
pour l'impôt que des banques comme comme
ça les rues voilà donc pourquoi sur 200
pays au monde aucun pays l'a pris parce
que c'était une grosse révolution
alors justement sur les expérimentations
attention plusieurs expérimentations
déjà été fait et la finlande
à partir du 1er janvier prochain va
mettre en place ce système et la france
aussi en gironde
donc quand même beaucoup sont intéressés
et on suppose que ça peut marcher
alors la finlande c'est ce n'est qu'une
expérimentation ne confondait jamais si
un jour où travaille dans une entreprise
ne dit jamais qu'une expérimentation
comme cela donc ça veut dire que c'est
ça d'être généralisé on peut pas gagner
à ginza l'alaska en 82 ç'avait été
testés on a été aboutis un revenu de 80
euros par mois
les pays-bas néerlandais s'y opposent il
ne s'y oppose et après l'expérience de
quatre villes aux pays-bas la suisse
vient de rejeter cette idée par un
référendum à 77% mais tout à l'heure
vous dise quand je parle de monsieur
vous est pris tout de suite sa défense
bon en disant que ce n'est pas sa
proposition
j'utilisais et lui ils veulent imposer
ça coûte quand même ça coûte quand même
je crois
l'huile et sur la base de 3 700
milliards on cite des expériences comme
vous venez de le faire que ça marche que
ça y est il ya un état qui ait décidé
lequel alors le débat n'est pas à faire
avec moi et j'aime pas pour vous avez
pris la défense des bleus noirs ne s'est
pas une condition de nous y sommes vous
les connaissiez sais je vous connais
vous faire réagir simplement abbas est
réussi donc il ya des expérimentations
est ce que vous ne serez pas favorable à
une expérimentation pour voir si ça
marche parce que l'idée quand même c'est
à la première idée c'est quand même de
vaincre la pauvreté c'est à dire que
méquignon des certaines en france ici en
france ne veut pas lutter contre la
pauvreté vous vous laissiez contre la
pauvreté en l'enrichissant le pays
donc en sortant du départ du débat
répartition nist ainsi quand vous allez
voir comment on fait de la croissance de
demain oui hélas quand vous aurez
augmenté que vous pourrez rembourser vos
dettes payer vos retraites et payer le
modèle social qui est qui et quand vous
allez chez le médecin c'est à crédit
quand vous allez à l'hôpital
ça vous coûte pas trop cher et ça crédit
que vous avez payez plus tard donc temps
que vous avez pas augmenter la richesse
pour payer tout cela comment voulez vous
dire allez je vais proposer une nouvelle
allocation pour pour pourquoi en plus
comme par hasard c'est vraiment un des
lecteurs mais je pense pas à vous je ne
traite pas lectorat liste mais j'en vois
beaucoup car avec ça qu'ils en parlent
d'un électorat ça plaît aux gens qu'on
ne connaissait pas l'économie quand vous
ne connaissez pas l'économie réelle
attention chers amis l'économie réelle
c'est parce qu'on apprend à l'université
quand on crée une entreprise quand on
voit les dépenses les recettes comme on
crée de la richesse comme on dirige des
hommes c'était ça on en sait beaucoup
plus comment on produit de ce match de
basket réagissait 25 ans l'entreprise
d'accord dans des grands rôles dans les
pme j'ai fait une chose de ma vie
professionnelle je ne suis pas un
universitaire c'est ça qu'on s'est un
peu de profit ce qu'on appelle à 100 de
vos vies c'est à dire il faut produire
de la richesse ifrad pour pouvoir les
redistribuer diriger le marketing du
plus gros logiciels développés en europe
oui effectivement je fais à 70 par des
quand il était militaire fumeux qu'ils
aient ou non mais non c'est un bordel
c'est un modèle théorique votre truc
hein non mais c'est vrai qu'il est
surtout basé sur beaucoup d'échangés
beaucoup de personnes qui sont dans les
communes réel j'étais encore en tant
qu'ancien président
des cars monde alors on sera avec
beaucoup de gens justement est ce que j
lo est un sujet de rupture forte et donc
ça va impacter bon beaucoup de choses et
donc c'est pas un travail qu'on fait
comme ça dans notre coin entre eux entre
le jean slim non pas du tout justement
beaucoup de gens pour pour terminer sur
cette note c'est quand même une autre
idée de l'organisation de la société
d'avoir un revenu qui permettrait de ne
pas travailler ou pas travailler que
partiellement
un mot sur cette philosophie un peu
nouvelle alors les philosophies là
dessus c'est bon pour moi ce sera pareil
tu nous tiens sur les libertés pour moi
le point important c'est que pour que
les personnes dans un magasin dans un
pays vous appelle à vous les gens se
respectent
il faut que les personnes et une liberté
de faire des choix rationnels et si les
gens sont contraints pour le fait qu'ils
doivent aller chercher à vous fait il a
vampire 12 formulaire qui la firent des
déclarations des preuves et insipide en
permanence ces gens là ne peuvent pas
vivre vivre au sens voilà faire des
choix rationnels pourquoi serions-nous
pris par deux les 200 pays qu'il y ait
dans le monde si c'est aussi revenir
simple que ça va venir je suppose que ça
va venir vous avez vous êtes devant une
explosion une explosion démographique
dans mieux de recevoir tout le monde
mais très bien mais vous allez donc
devoir de partager en deux si vous devez
faire ce nouveau système redistributif
puisque vous allez augmenter leur
distribution
vous allez avoir des subventions à / de
votre niveau de vie mais pourquoi pas
mais moins qu'on se le dise qu'on ne
dise pas que ce rapatriement séquence de
demain si vous répartissez le social
comme ça de façon légale et du plus ou
moins parce qu'ils jugent économique
délicat et bien le type qui aura un
malheur qui aura 100 mille cent mille
euros et des opérations quelques petits
coups de 5050 milles euros les mêmes
cinq cent mille euros
mais il y aura plus parce qu'on aura
répartis en vingt mille euros quand il
le roi à peu près tout le monde vous
verrez que ramène au plus le système de
santé ne seraient plus financées c'est
très clair dans cette logique de mots de
conclusion marque de baskets
voilà donc ce soir devant un débat très
rapide fictivement qui montrent que
c'est un sujet de cette nature qui est
un sujet extrêmement compliqué il est
très facile de tomber dans la caricature
et il me paraît important que dans un
pays comme la france on arrive à passer
à autre chose et de regarder les choses
meilleures peut-être plus techniques
plus précises
en écoutant vraiment c'est que les uns
et les autres à dire ce sujet là à
chaque fois repartir dans la caricature
ça lui prend pas beaucoup avancé
d'accord merci jean michel fourgous
votre conclusion de mots d'écouter les
35 heures cette vers apporté plein de
choses et je crois que monsieur monsieur
notre grand leader avant les deux mêlant
chant puis tu dis moi je vais créer
trois millions et demi d'emplois
on est sur la même ligne moi j'attends
j'attends demain c'est sérieux diriger
un pays la france étant est en dépôt de
bilan
vous le savez c'est très grave
aujourd'hui il faut augmenter la
richesse et on le répartit sionisme on
verra quand on aura augmenté le pibe de
2 à 3% pour sauver le système social
français pour tous les gens modestes
moyens est haute pour tous les français
merci jean michel fourgous
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition de 7,8 le débat
[Musique]